[Music]
well hello everyone
and welcome to this virtual edition of
film independent presents
our year-round member uh screening
series
i'm josh welsh i'm president of film
independent and before we get started
um with today's program i want to give a
special shout out to some of film
independence
um most generous and loyal supporters um
first of all thank you to our incredible
lead sponsor the hollywood foreign press
association thank you to our virtual
screening partner vision media
without whom we wouldn't be able to do
this
our official media partner the los
angeles times
and lastly our promotional partner kcrw
thank you to all of you
um for your support year round
especially as as we moved our
programming online
your support means so much um i also
want to thank focus features
um as well first and foremost and as
well
i want to thank um award-winning
filmmaker spirit award nominee don
porter
and photojournalist and master thrower
of shade
pizza for being here today um
for anyone watching who's uh perhaps new
to film independent i just briefly want
to mention film independent
we're a film arts organization based in
los angeles we are a
membership organization open access if
you love film or you're a filmmaker
please uh go to our website and join
become a member
members vote on the winners of the film
independent spirit awards which will be
happening next year on
april the 24th later than usual um but
keeping our spot a day before the oscars
and um just go to our website you can
learn a lot about what we do
so with that um don and pete thank you
so much for being here for taking time
to to do yet another zoom call i suspect
you've been doing a lot of them
um but let me start by saying how i i
love the film i found it so
pleasurable to watch it's a deeply it's
a moving film
and just so enjoyable on so many levels
both the content and the
the filmic the the craft of it um so
my first question really it's for both
of you and i don't know the answers to
it is how did this project come together
i don't know if you had a pre-existing
relationship or if you came together
specifically
on this project but um either one of you
want to field that
sure i'll start um first of all thank
you josh for
having us um as a former spirit award
nominee
like i know how a cool it is and uh
important but also this year is so tough
that
um giving you know kind of amplifying
these independent movies
is so important and so difficult so we
really appreciate it
um i was just a fan of pete's you know
um on social media like you know
two million other people um and
then uh jamie lemons uh who's producing
partners with laura dern
uh and they were working with evan hayes
who produced freestyle
um they kind of i was at another like
awards
um ceremony i think it was the ida's and
uh you know how they have that outdoor
like courtyard it's all pretty
and it's like the one time of year that
documentary people get to go on the
paramount lot so we really like it
like the food is really good so we're
out there and it's like the trees are
nice and it's
la weather nice and like evan starts
like coming towards me and i didn't know
evan at the time
so i thought he was trying to get around
me so i was like moving out of the way
and he's like no no i want
i was like okay who's this stalker um
but
uh he you know said i want to talk to
you about a project but it was like at a
cocktail party so it wasn't exactly the
time
to talk about projects so um i
uh went to la i met up with with uh
evan and jamie and laura um and then
they said well can you meet pete
so p came uh to her conference room in
los
angeles and he just brings his laptop
and he you know opens it and starts
going he does a kind of a version of the
one-man show he has
and he starts going through the pictures
and i just was
like overcome like with what i was
feeling
seeing the pictures and um so that's
you know when i was kind of sold on the
project but i think pete had been
speaking with jamie and evan
um and probably laura for a bit before
that so i'll let him tell you about that
yeah so for me it was actually right
around a couple years ago
um jamie and i had this mutual friend
um patrick jordan who at the time was
a co-manager of brandi carlisle who's a
who's a friend of mine so one day i get
this email from patrick
saying hey this friend of mine wants to
talk to you about this potential project
can i
link the two of you up um and i was like
sure so i get this email from jamie
and then fast forward to the next time i
was in la
i meet jamie and evan they come to one
of my presentations
and they start you know start
i guess working on me about potentially
doing this
uh project so that's kind of how it
started out and then
as as don said later on i came back to
l.a
and met laura and uh and don
and i have to say it was a little
intimidating doing
um doing doing my presentation
in front of four people because i was
usually doing it in front of
you know eight hundred a thousand people
sort of sort of more anonymous
if you will like you know i'm up on
stage and there's people out in the
audience
but suddenly i'm in this little tiny
conference room with just four people
and they keep interrupting me to ask me
questions and i was evan
it sort of put me like like i didn't
feel i was
you know projecting my presentation in
the
in the effective way that i usually am
and
in fact i guess uh they they were
affected
uh despite the the circumstances
so pete i i have a follow-up question
for you on that which is
i mean you've been in the public eye for
a long time and people have
known who you are but i'm curious what
the experience
was like for you becoming the subject of
a film and a photographer
as opposed to being the one doing the
documenting was it
i mean did did it just come naturally to
you were you uncomfortable
oh my gosh he loved it he loved it so
much he was like what do you need to do
no i i i you know i was
was not well first of all it took some
convincing
to get me to agree to
to do this just because um
yeah i mean i'm sort of in the public
eye on social media but i'm still
kind of anonymous in a lot of ways and
so
this meant giving up my anonymity so you
know i had to
wanted to make sure that that i could
get my wife on board
because you know it just it changes
it kind of changes things a little bit
and
um and then you know it just it's just a
little uncomfortable
to have the camera turned on you i mean
not
not to take away the great people that
don
and and that had working with her
um the the crew were they were all great
and so it wasn't it wasn't that it was
just like just the
i don't know just being on the other
side is just like kind of a weird
dynamic for me yeah yeah
don you i don't even know how you did
this but you have two films this year of
course you have the john lewis
documentary
and then and then the pizza documentary
and
i i'm sure they overlapped at some point
and i'm just can you talk a bit about
sort of
how you navigated that and um
and and i'm assuming both of the films
you were finishing them during
some part of covet and sort of talk a
bit about that
yeah um so i was
kind of midway a little bit past that in
john lewis movie
and um when i you know met up with
evan jamie and laura and uh
you know i mean the the secret to
independent documentaries
and filmmaking is that you really it's
very rare that you can do just one thing
and you know kind of keep everything
going so
it's not unusual to have things overlap
but i don't usually have them overlapped
so quickly
um um but you know
as soon as i saw pete's pictures laid
out the way that he did it
i was like first of all i really wanted
to do it um
and you know felt like it was important
it wasn't just like
another project it was important and
timely but the second thing
is um i felt like the movies spoke to
each other
you know john lewis is was all about i
have a hard time with the past test this
was all about um encouraging people to
speak up
when they see something wrong and here
that's exactly what pete
is doing right now and so it felt like
just the perfect thing to segue into
even though they're different people
and different um so so it was really
um i was just kind of determined to
figure it out
so um but you know i i and actually i
worked with the same editor on both
films jessica congdon
so it's probably even harder for her i
mean she got no break
she just is like and then go on so
we were kind of jess and i work really
well together so we were like
in a nice groove with john lewis movie
um and we basically finished shooting we
were in the edit
so i could pick up and go you know start
to
start to follow pete i mean i think the
harder thing with pete's movie is
i was a very aware
i had a lot of reverence for the
pictures
and so i wanted to figure out what was
the right balance
of kind of verite film
and and the pictures you know and the
still images and how do you
really celebrate the still image without
undercutting it
with the veritas so we spent a lot of
time
balancing that and then as far as kovid
we were done with john lewis movie in
late november
so um so that was fine
pete's movie we were not done with we
had other
interviews to set up i wanted to spend a
lot more time with
him um and
we just couldn't you know everybody went
into lockdown
um so we had to to get creative so
you know this movie uh i'm proud of both
movies
i think that they they really helped me
express some things i'm feeling at this
moment but you know this movie will
always be really special because
we just had to get really creative about
finishing it and everybody
every producer jess our assistant editor
our people were all over the place and
everyone just
no one complained they just like
everyone really believes in this film
and so you know kind of just really
laser focused
um on getting it done
so i know we have a lot probably a lot
of filmmakers watching this could you
talk a little bit more about how did you
handle those
the things that you hadn't shot when you
say you got creative
were you able to get those shoots like
working remotely
or we got a couple
um so first thing we did is we tried
zooming with pete
so there's some zoom footage in there
and that was like
okay um then
we sent him a camera package a black
magic camera
and that was a lot better um you know
pete's obviously knows his way around
the camera
um so you know was able to figure out
you know angles and lighting and all the
rest of us our dp
set the uh camera up you know as far as
like all our settings and then we mailed
that whole packet to peep and then i
would zoom with him and he would
we would do the interview so we did a
number that way um
and then for a couple of people samantha
power
she allowed us to have a crew in her
house but i was
zooming and she's in cambridge i'm
close by and i was like should i and she
was like let's just zoom
so so we did that so i've actually
gotten
pretty comfortable with the zoom
interview um
you know out of necessity but um
we're doing it you know color correct my
friend liz garvis
said use the ipad it will work
it kind of worked it was better than
nothing um
and then for sound i had done the last
several projects with skywalker sound
and i worked with the same mixer chris
barnett
at skywalker and so he kind of set us up
with the
apple four um
and he uploaded sequences so it was
almost like we were in the room except
that chris is really fun to be in the
room with
so i really i of everything i really
missed
the mix because going to skywalker is
fun
yeah and chris just like takes a lot of
care with the movie
and he makes you feel like you're mixing
tron 3
or something you know it's like a little
documentary and
you know he puts my name on the door
like yeah literally like like one time
trolls was next door and his trolls
and like you know my little film um so i
missed that
a lot uh but i also like chris is
usually the first person to see the
movie
like so for my last like four or five
projects
like he really knows he's like oh i like
this oh
this is good you know so so that's what
we did
wow it's remarkable i mean it's it's
interesting to hear the samantha power
piece
that would all that was beautifully shot
i you know
there's no sense of uh this is not a
zoom movie
right it's visually really rich and yeah
looks gorgeous
um so congrats um pete
i wanted to ask you so one of uh i've
known your work for a long time
you know from the obama years and i
remember the
christmas of 17 i think my wife gave me
your
the book your book on the obamas um
which i think for me and for so many
people that was a profoundly moving book
for
people who were living through that
moment for many people i would say i
mean it
in a way that i think photography books
maybe wouldn't have been in another year
right that it spoke to people in such a
personal emotional way
um but i wasn't familiar with your
previous work and
your background so it's great to learn
about and specifically that you
um previous to the obamas you've done
similar work to the official
photographer
in the reagan white house and that's one
of my favorite parts of the film is
seeing that footage
of you with the reagans and it is
straight i mean to me when i think of
presidents who've known how to see the
value of photography in a real way
it's like i don't know if you agree with
this listing but it'll be the kennedys
the reagans and the obamas
are the ones where it's like there's a
sense of that personal
connection through photography and a
sense of family
um and i'd love if you could just
elaborate a bit on
how did how did that reagan position
come together for you how long were you
doing that
and did and was it did you have the same
kind of access with the reagans that you
did with the obamas
yeah so i i came to the white house in
the middle of reagan's first term
in june of 83. so his
chief photographer michael evans hired
me
to to work under him and then he left
after the first term
and they didn't replace him so the
second term
there was kind of like a rotation we'd
rotation behind the scenes but it's
it's hard to do that you know where you
don't have one person who
is you know sort of doing everything
so my access was not nearly as good but
i do feel
that i made some some really good
intimate behind-the-scenes pictures
during the reagan administration it just
wasn't on a daily basis i would say
um and and not to
not to sort of disagree with with your
premise about kennedy's reagan's obama's
but i do think that the reagan
administration was more
aware of the stagecraft for
the tv networks that that was their
that was their focus was trying to
create this
this backdrop to put him in
uh and so it was much more stage managed
his presidency i i think just the way i
looked at it
which which didn't um didn't mean that
i wasn't able to make some pictures
behind the scenes as i say
it's just that was not a high priority
for them
um i have a question about a specific
set of photographs that you must have
done hundreds or thousands of but photos
in the oval office and i remember them
in your book i mean they're these
gorgeous photos
of obama sitting at the at the desk with
you know looking at a piece of paper or
facing the wall there's
lots of different shots but the that you
know the way that you would
get the light bouncing off something
onto his face
and you must have shot i'm assuming you
shot reagan at that desk and then you
shot obama at that test
so many times could you talk about as a
photographer how you approach that to
keep it fresh
or i don't know just you know
the repetition of that and finding like
these
you know rembrandt like images of of the
light
coming up and they're just gorgeous and
moving photos
well i mean the interesting thing about
the oval office was the the
the light was different
there different times of the day and
different times of the year
so for me my favorite time
of the year was when the leaves were off
the trees
because that meant you know there was
more sunlight
uh coming in to the oval office
and then my favorite time of the day
would would be late in the afternoon
when there was that backlight that came
in
on the desk and you could if things
worked out right you could
you know we get a reflection as you say
off the papers or
or whatever but you know it never
it didn't always come into place like
you know you know my job was not to like
direct him
in any way it's just how things unfolded
i had to be ready for
so certainly at those that time of the
year
meaning in the winter late afternoon
my sense of light was heightened by
maybe today will be the day that all the
elements will come together
and you'll get that really cool picture
and then conversely during the summer
when the sun is higher the leaves are on
the trees
the oval office is a lot flatter in
terms of the lighting and that made it
challenging to try to
you know still make pictures with
whatever light happens to be
available that sort of answers your
question
yeah yeah absolutely i thought i mean
the other
angle on the oval office is when you
would have there's so many shots of
you know a group of people in there for
a meeting where you're not shooting
towards the
light from the window but i guess it's
flatter lighting but the drama in the
photo is in
the the physical postures of people the
looks on their faces the
the who's in the room whether it's men
women people of color
like all of that is just again this the
sense of drama that you capture there's
so much well i mean i mean also uh
trying to incorporate you know some of
the historic elements whether it be
you know the painting of george
washington the painting of abraham
lincoln
or there you know he had the bust of mlk
and it there's a picture in the film and
in the book
where i i've got this picture where the
bust is in the foreground and
in the background he's talking to these
uh
activists that had protested in ferguson
after the events in ferguson
and you know i tell people like i it
took me five years to get that picture
because the elements never came together
i was always aware
of trying to make a picture like that
but it just never came together
until that moment where just all the
elements
you know he happened to be standing in
just the right place with these
these young adults um you know and i've
got the bust in the foreground
and the painting of lincoln um so i was
always aware of my surroundings and
hopefully trying to
incorporate those into my photography
but sometimes it worked and sometimes it
didn't
don um you know that the word
inspirational is so
tired out and often just overused to the
point of being meaningless but
i want to say i found the john lewis
film and this film
like inspirational in a very real sense
and to watch them at this moment
i mean there's there are lots of
different types of documentary film and
there's
i mean you've made other types of film
earlier in your career like
films focus on particular issues that
can be very like you know films dealing
with
with justice and racism and police
brutality and the
justice system right and there's all
kinds of
hard-hitting documentary films that
educate one and and you know galvanize
people but i found your two films this
year are so
like in a not a corny way but in like a
really important way
uplifting and inspiring and i'm great
and
and there's an element of pleasure to
that too where i'm just like
you just want to bathe in these it's and
this film in particular i mean it's
inspiring it's it's a portrait of an
artist pete
and his commitment to his craft and and
it's also of course
still a portrait of those eight years of
the obamas that's captured in the
photographs it's also inspiring
i'm just wondering i don't know if you
want to just talk about that do you
think about that
what like this
yeah 100 i think about that quite a bit
um you know what i think about a lot
and what's you know uh hang on i'm gonna
tell my son to be quiet
um there was like about to be
inappropriate music in the background of
your live stream
um you know if you think about it my
film gideon's army
you know made in 2010 my film trapped
made in 2013.
um those were trying to shine a light
on things that were happening while
president obama was president
um and you know for me i felt like
the government was in solid hands and
there was a person in power
and a government in power you know doing
their best
and we needed to show them or show kind
of everyone
things that were not going well you know
and and it was kind of it's almost for
me like i could take it
you know i could really like dig into
those tough subjects
um because you know the world wasn't
falling apart
like it is right now and for this movie
and for john lewis movie
i think as an audience and me as a
filmmaker and as a person as a mother
as a wife as a friend i needed a
different kind of movie
i need a kind of movie to make me
believe and that's really what i was
looking for
in subjects because you know living
under this president
i'm depressed enough you know and which
is not to say i don't read the newspaper
and i don't keep up with things but i
feel like
um there are a lot of people like me who
are just we just need to be reminded
that there's good in the world there's
good in government
um and that things don't need to be this
dark
and that we can look towards the light
and
you know kind of live to work another
day
so um so definitely it's the kind of
movie i wanted to see myself
you know i wanted to see something that
was not pollyanna
and not you know um false
but also was hopeful yeah
i mean to me one of the things that runs
through this film in so many different
layers is is empathy i mean there's
empathy that you just feel it throughout
the film it's like
the way that you're shooting pete and
talking to him and giving him space to
talk about his craft
the way pete you filmed the obamas and
just seeing that in your relationship
with that family and that administration
and it's just
manifesting your work and then of course
the empathy that
the obama's just embodied you know for
the country it's like i i mean
i don't know how else to put it but i
just felt like there's just empathy
running through this film on all these
different levels
um i don't know if that's something that
either or both of you have thought about
or um and it feels like something again
and that this will sound to
some people might hear this as a
partisan comment for me and i really
don't mean it like that but i feel like
it's in such
short supply that sort of empathy and
you know willingness to take somebody
seriously and and i don't know you know
see their humanity it's
uh well let me quote michelle obama for
a second
um you know michelle
said that the presidency doesn't change
who you are it reveals who you are
and um and i think that's true with my
photographs too
i think behind the scenes photographs of
a president
can reveal who they are and
it it just so happens that most
presidents
including president obama um
they're empathetic that's part of their
character
is being empathetic and compassionate
and um they know that presidency
is not about him it's not the presidency
it's not about one person it's about us
and when you contrast that with what we
have today
you don't see empathy you don't see
compassion
you see an individual who cares about
one person himself um
and like even today he tweets out
this offhanded comment about our people
and there is no there is no like our
people
when you're the president united states
every citizen
you represent every citizen in the
country
and he still doesn't get that and i
think
hopefully in this film and in my
photography
you you see what an empathetic and
compassionate
um person
barack obama is
yeah so pete that leads me to my next
question which is
a huge and it's a big part of the film
is your decision
to launch an instagram account and uh
you know effectively start throwing
shade at the current president but
through your posts and it's it marks a
big
shift for you as a photojournalist where
previously when you were
in the white house taking pictures or
working in news you your opinions were
kept out of it
and now you're sharing your work in a
new way where it's directly addressing
the current occupant of the white house
and um
i mean this is a big part of the film so
people who are watching this who've seen
the film kind of know about this but
as a as a follow-up question on that was
this something that you wrestled with
for a long time before doing
or was it just obvious to you that you
had this you wanted to speak up in this
way
i would say that i wrestled with it
because you know i did
my first shade post on january 21st
2017.
so obviously i didn't wrestle with it
that much but i will say that i was i
was i was very subtle
at first and and tried to be humorous
about it
um but you know to me right away just
because of the things i just talked
about i
i knew i had to speak out um
you know and i thought you know i'm a
private citizen now
and um it you know to paraphrase
don's former subject john lewis
if you see something wrong say something
and i couldn't just
you know i couldn't sit home and not do
do anything i had to do something
and i felt i came at it from a unique
perspective
having worked for for both a republican
and democratic president
um and you know and i
i thought i could i could offer um
[Music]
some uh contrast maybe
with uh with what a normal presidency
looks like and feels like and looks like
um compared to what you know what we
have today
it's a really interesting uh i mean
first of all your posts on instagram do
have so much humor
um they're also in you're re
reusing or repurposing photographs that
you know
some of us have already seen we're
familiar with those photos but seeing
them now in this totally new
context where they're being directly
juxtaposed to something
happening in the news today with the
current administration it's like
it's bringing the photograph to life in
in a really unexpected new way which i
just i love it
um um
so one thing i noticed in the film
there was footage of the transition
between obama and trump there was like
the i saw i remember seeing video
footage
and like you're you're pointing out that
moment when you noticed that the secret
service was now following trump rather
than obama
but i didn't see did you get photos were
you photographing in the white house
like the day that trump came to visit
like immediately after the election did
you get shots of them together alone
or was that kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah
we we the the only one we included in
the film was
uh it was a it was a
picture where he president obama was
given trump a tour
of the you know oval office complex if
you will
and there's a picture if you remember
where
you you just see trump's hand and his
the back of his head
looking into the private study um
but i don't know i mean i don't think i
don't think i don't think
i feel compelled i don't think don felt
compelled
that we needed to show photographs from
that in that day
okay it was too sad
yeah i can only imagine
um and so
pete if if now i mean you it is a big
step for you to take to do
what like what you're doing on instagram
and yeah you're a private citizen and
everybody can have an instagram account
but does this uh
i mean could you does it shift your
career in a particular way does it limit
you in ways like
yeah i think my career is over
but you know it's it's sort of like you
know i'm
you know i'm kind of winding down anyway
and um
uh i i again i just felt that i i
couldn't
i could not say anything that i had to
speak out and
if it if it means that you know my
photojournalism
photojournalism career is over so be it
i'm
not going to lose any sleep over it
there's still other types of photography
i can do
yeah so we've got a ton of questions
have come in
from our audience and i'm just gonna i
don't know if i mean i doubt i'm gonna
get to them all but let me just quickly
go up here
um can i answer the one about i i see
the question
can i just answer the one about the
azorian community my grandparents are
from the azores so somebody asked about
that i have to tell you that last year i
was at i was in the azores
um and there were so many
reporters wanting to interview me um
and
uh and i i created a few headlines i
think in the azores by
calling trump a um a con man
and uh the next day's newspaper was like
uh that i had called him
vigorista which i guess is the closest
portuguese word for
con man
so going up to the top here uh i feel
like you may have already answered this
but
um the first person says my question if
joe biden is elected
uh and asks you to come back to be the
white house photographer again would you
do it
yeah i'm holding out for a cabinet
position instead
no i mean i think that um i'm i'm of the
age
um and and that this job just takes so
much
out of you that
um i i don't think that i could do this
job again
because um you know my family sacrificed
enough for eight years where i didn't
really get
much of a personal life and um you know
i have a granddaughter now and i want to
spend some time with her so i don't
think it's in the cards for me
i will i will say that i am going to do
everything
i can to make sure that whoever joe
biden knock on wood
hires that that person have
the level of access that i had to
president obama
and i will be reaching out not only to
the photographer
whoever that will be uh but i'll
probably
reach out to joe biden and um
you know tell him the importance of
having somebody
make these images for history
you know it's something you you touch on
towards the end of the film is the fact
that
uh trump doesn't really have a right he
limits photography to
someone to document official functions
but there there isn't anybody sort of
documenting behind the scenes what's
happening
and on the one hand that seems like
obvious that he would approach it that
way but i'm just curious
were you at all surprised that he but
given that he comes in some
broad sense from media and should
understand the value of
images and you know the visual medium
i'll say a couple of things i have no no
inside knowledge about you know
what whether the current white house
photographer has the kind of access that
i
have or not we don't we're not seeing
those pictures right
um what's what's interesting though is
that
the the current white house photo office
has
posted twice more than twice as many
pictures
on flickr than we did in
all eight years they've already sort of
doubled
our final total but you know most of the
pictures
are 99.5 percent of them are
you know from the reality show it's just
like you know
the public events and um you know you
don't really see
the kind of behind the scenes photos and
whether and and i don't know i have no
inside knowledge whether that's because
they
don't have access or they're choosing
not to post them i don't know
one of the most amazing moments in the
film for me was that contrast between
the trump photo in the situation room
that seems totally staged
and also has horrible lighting and just
these like four or five guys
facing forward versus what was happening
i don't know if it's in that same room
or not but with the night of
osama bin laden was killed and you see
the obama team
arraign just the contrast of those two
photographs
is speaks volumes uh
of photography and also of leadership
and
uh great to see that in in the film
um uh another question has
obama seen the film and if so his
reactions or thoughts
not sure so i mean i just emailed him on
uh
see today's monday i think i'd fry i
sort of lose track on
thursday thursday or friday i was
emailing with him
and um he you know he was busy you know
he's busy with his book and stuff
writing his book and so i didn't want to
uh bother him but
but i think he's going to see it i can't
remember if it's this week or next week
so as far as i know he hasn't seen it
yet but you will see this
see it soon uh question for don
on how you crafted this the story arc in
the film after reviewing all the footage
um and how and when did you decide that
pete should uh narrate his own uh his
own
story um you know
uh i worked really closely with jessica
condon
uh the great editor and um
we wanted we had we kind of identified
our objectives
um you know we had the benefit of being
able to see the photos
before we started which usually
you start shooting and then you see what
you have and here we had the opportunity
to think
um and actually the organization was
somewhat inspired by
a speech we heard pete give which is
you know he talked about the qualities
that you need in a presidency you know
empathy
compassion etc um and so we kind of ran
with those themes that pete had laid out
and then we started um the daunting but
really
fun process of gathering
you know our first passive pictures i
mean pete took
two million photographs um there were
tens of thousands that were kind of
available for us to
to play with um all credit goes to our
junior editor ben zweig he spent many
happy weeks
paging through photos um kind of guided
by the themes that we were looking for
but we all have like our favorite images
and so everybody got their favorite
image um
and then you know jess and ben and i
really kind of
narrowed down to you know kind of
buckets
of photos that we were really interested
in and then we brought pete into that
process
and he you know he would see you know he
didn't know what the film was
going to be but he could see what images
we were gravitating towards
and then he was like well you should
look at this one you should look at this
one i mean one thing i should say is
pete has
an insane memory i mean he can pretty
much
that that little bit with trevor noah
where trevor says do you have a picture
for everything
you know stupid trump does and he says
pretty much
um i mean we saw that in real time we
would say
oh we're looking for this and pete you
know
nine times out of ten could point us if
not to the exact photo
to kind of the moment in time where we
should be
looking um so it was you know it was a
lot but it was like
a fun task it was like going through
willy wonka's chocolate factory
you know somebody's got to do it um so
we had a lot of fun doing that that's
great um we have a question here from
marjan safinia um who says dawn this was
such an incredible film
so powerful it moved me deeply that
final thought from ben rose was so
powerful
when you heard him say that did you know
that that would be your capper
um yes i mean
uh ben rhodes is such a gifted
uh he's such a gift with words but
um more than that he has such a sincere
and deep um interest in the well-being
of this country
and so that is i think what he was
really
leaning into and that is really how we
felt so
um we actually tried that comment a few
places but it was just such a good
you know wrap up that um i think it
worked really well
where it is so thank you for noticing
that a question for
pete uh the image of washington politics
often seems fixed
but what have you seen change
stylistically aesthetically since your
career began
big question
um you know and not really sure how to
answer that other than
um i i remember back in the the reagan
days there was a guy named steve crowley
who was a still photographer
first for the washington times and then
the new york times
and he he would go to the same event as
everybody else
and make this picture that nobody else
would see he just had this intuitive
sense of
making a picture that really spoke to
what was taking place more than anybody
else
and um and there was nobody
doing what he was doing and now like
even in the trump era
i mean i follow many of the
photographers that cover
the white house on a regular basis
and there are so many great
photographers that
are really have their eye out for these
little subtle details you know whether
it be
i i i mean i can't i can't ever like the
pictures on
on instagram because they're of a
subject that i
detest but they're just they're
brilliantly done
um and so i don't i don't know i think
the
i think the the the number of
photographers
working the washington scene have just
gotten
exponentially better
that's great to hear um another question
for you pete
can you discuss how you review your own
uh
personal editing style of your daily
photo intake and do you retouch things
in photoshop
with the volume of that's a great
question just given the volume of
photos you were taking in the white
house
um yeah i mean i think the the only time
i really got
a chance to review my images
was on more on a monthly basis where
um we we would we would do a a catalog
of images from the previous month
behind the scenes and use and that would
really be the only
time that i would have that i would have
a chance to actually go through my own
pictures in terms of retouching
the only thing we ever did was adjust
color balance and then brightness and
contrast
um so just basically following the
accepted photojournalism practices
the one exception to that
was uh during the bilateral that the
you know the kind of iconic photo
there was a classified document on the
table
that we had to uh you know blur out
pixelize
um but we we um we uh
made sure that we were transparent about
that we had done that
um a related question and i had this
same question as i was watching the film
do you own the rights to the photos
or does the white house or the u.s
government um
are you allowed to what are you allowing
yeah so we we
we they're they're considered public
domain so
anybody can use them wow uh in
you know an editorial sense i mean the
the only restriction is like for
instance
if there was a picture of president
obama wearing an ll bean jacket
l.l bean couldn't use that photograph
you know to advertise because
there's still laws protecting the
likeness
of the president even when he was the
former president
so there's some re there's some
restrictions around that but
and i will say also too that every
single image
that i made both in the reagan and the
obama administration
every single image is
archived and is now at the national
archives
okay right you know i'll just add
quickly i saw a question about where did
we get the behind the scenes
footage um julie for reagan that was
courtesy of the reagan library
and uh it was really fun as a filmmaker
to go back
through that but especially i mean you
should have heard the shouts for joy
when we found
pete with the mustache um pete on the
table
pete you know uh coaching nancy and ron
and you know when when reagan says did
you get that pete
you did i mean it was just like made
my year as a as a filmmaker so
there's a lot you know there's a lot
there if you look for it
um there's a lot around and and just to
just just to sort of uh
i i wouldn't say differentiate but so
each presidential library there's an
aspect of it that
attached to the national archives so
when dawn says she got it from the
reagan library
there's there's actually somebody from
the national archives that's
administering
the the archive of images and video
that's housed at the reagan library but
it the the images themselves don't
belong to the library they belong to the
national archives i mean that's kind of
a
splitting years but i love that scene
when
reagan comes up with the idea of having
nancy hold the
the chainsaw like this guy definitely
comes from hollywood he's a kid
right great moment
um uh somebody asked pete you refer to
making pictures rather than taking them
is there a reason for that i don't know
it's like that's sort of an ansel adams
thing you know and
that's a quote from ansel adams that you
know take a picture you make a picture
yeah um i sometimes use it
i interchange those terms
uh and then in closing a question for
both of you which many people here have
asked
what this is a crazy question because
you're just launching this film but
everybody wants to know what's next for
both of you um dawn to start with you is
two films in one year is not enough like
are you starting work on uh a new
project or developing something
yeah um i'm working on a six part series
for apple
uh with oprah winfrey and prince harry
it's about mental health so um
you're really excited about it um
they've both participated they're very
involved
you know we have bi-weekly calls so uh
it's it's a totally different totally
different kind of thing
interesting and pete how about you
um well i think for me it kind of
depends on on uh
what happens in the election to be
honest right yeah yeah
um uh hopefully i can close the chapter
on
uh shade um in
next january um and then i still you
know i still
want to be active as a as a photographer
and
i also am interested in in
in doing more uh education
um i i enjoy
um talking to young photographers and uh
i wanna i don't wanna do it on a on a
like a
permanent basis like i don't want to
teach full-time but i do
would like to to continue to do
workshops and
and lectures with uh geared towards
uh young photographers
you know there's one other question here
that i think is interesting i want to
ask from
jeffrey fenner where he says since the
shade photos are a bit like
obama throwing shade himself have you
felt obligated to get his permission
before posting any of them
uh no because and actually
i say that because um i didn't want
people to think that he was somehow in
cahoots with me
you know what i mean i didn't i i
thought it was important
to just to keep that separation
um and he like he's he knew i was
out i was up to you know he has friends
that look at instagram
i don't think he looks at instagram
himself so
you know he i think he knows what i was
up to
but it wasn't i don't think he's like
you know
checking out instagram every week or two
well um i want to thank both of you i
mean first and foremost thank you for
this
beautiful film uh thank you for sharing
it with the film independent community
and and thank you so much for being here
for this conversation
um these are crazy times and dawn
anything film independent can do to mp
to to help
build the the audience and word around
this film we want to
we want to help um to anyone watching
um please uh spread the word let people
know that about this film it is coming
out
uh theatrically later this month uh
and then it will be on i believe msnbc i
might i hope i'm not misspeaking
from focus and then on msnbc um
but uh thank you so much i've really
enjoyed talking with you
and um best of luck to both of you stay
stay safe and healthy
[Music]